Donald Trump should sue in West Virginia
where 86% of West Virginians are huge
Trump fans and the jury pool would be
like we are impartial and Trump should
sue her for defamation in West Virginia
the question is why does he not if Trump
went to West Virginia and said oh I got
a house here I I'm suing her here he'd
win in two seconds he'd win $83.33
million in fact he'd win simply because
I guarantee you you you you you pull 100
West Virginia about this and they're
going to be pissed off not everybody's
going to know about it don't get me
wrong but if they know they're going to
be like they're doing what to Donald
Trump in fact you go to the W you go to
Western Maryland okay Maryland which is
you know Baltimore is basically got its
boot on it and we went to a we went to a
diner and they had flags of Donald Trump
riding a tank standing on a tank with
fireworks exploding and him holding like
an Uzi there's one of him on a
velociraptor and I'm like these people
love Donald Trump Donald sue her back
and do it here